ces manifestants ne relâchent pas leurs
efforts
derrière leurs barricades de fortune ils
continuent de crier leur hostilité à la
junte militaire birmane des militaires
qui poursuivent une répression violente
contre leurs opposants partout dans le
pays
dans le centre mais aussi dans le
nord-est et à rangoun
de nombreux témoignages rapportent des
exécutions sommaires et de très nombreux
blessés
l'association d'assistance aux
prisonniers politiques a de son côté
déjà dénombré au moins 60 civils tués et
près de 2000 arrestations depuis le coup
d'état du 1er février
une situation qui inquiète les nations
unies le peuple de birmanie n'a pas
seulement besoin de mots de soutien
mais il a aussi besoin d'actions de
soutien il a besoin de l'aide de la
communauté internationale et il en a
besoin maintenant je suis conscient que
toutes les nations ne sont pas prêtes à
agir mais la réticence de quelques
nations à agir ne devrait pas interdire
ou limiter l'action coordonnée de celles
qui le sont les actions coordonnées des
nations travaillant ensemble seront les
plus efficaces fait une inquiétude
également partagée par la russie
nous sommes préoccupés par les
informations provenant de la bae faisant
état d'un nombre croissant de victimes
au sein de la population civile
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
a fermement condamné les violences en
birmanie malgré les pressions
internationales le pouvoir militaire
birman résiste l'armée a ainsi accusé
l'ancien chef du gouvernement en dessous
çi d'avoir reçu 600 mille dollars et
plus de 11 kg d'or en guise de pots de
vin la lauréate du prix nobel de la paix
renversé par le putsch a de plus été
assigné à résidence dans un lieu tenu
secret elle avait déjà été inculpée pour
violation d'une loi sur les
télécommunications et incitation aux
troubles publics
la chute de l'ancienne icône de la
démocratie birmane a mis fin à une
décennie de transition démocratique en
birmanie